le spd de this et nos presque barbare
mais qui selon les dirigeants de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
devrait être un véritable booster pour
notre économie bonjour marinette tories
bonjour monsieur vialleton brochures aux
auditrices et auditeurs de maintien que
la première conseillère exécutive en
charge du développement économique le st
daisy schéma territorial de
développement économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation avec quatre
grands axes la probable l'employabilité
la durabilité la compétitivité et
l'attractivité c'est la martinique
entrepreneuriale qui se dessine tout à
fait c'est d'abord ce schéma qui a été
donc élaboré de façon partenariale avec
tous les acteurs économiques tous nos
partenaires économiques sur le
territoire
c'est à dire les consulaires les pc
kacem cap nord et spa sud
les services de l'état naturellement
donc on s'est tous mis là on a tout dit
on a travaillé et on a élaboré ce schéma
avec son plan d'action et sa de
l'orientation c'est une feuille de route
comme j'aime à dire c'est un guide
pratique pour l'entrepreneuriat pour
ceux qui sont déjà dans l'entreprenariat
et ceux qui veulent y entrer
c'est sur son dispositif voulu pour
toutes les régions de france la
martinique également avec une petite
spécificité
vous avez décidé d'y ajouter d'y ajouter
un plan d'action tout à fait oui parce
que ce plan d'action ça permet de ne pas
avoir un schéma comme tous les schémas
qui ce qu'ils ont fait de bonnes
intentions d'orientation et puis qui
reste là donc nous avons voulu le rendre
opérationnel jeudi immédiatement donc
toujours avec nos partenaires nous avons
travaillé sur mes actions pour pouvoir
habiller et à dire traduire ce schéma
est donc nous avons plus d'une
soixantaine d'actions avec un
financement déjà fléchi d'un visa
millions d'euros mobilisables un peu
plus de 800 millions d'euros vous dites
qu'ils peuvent être mobilisés pour ce
schéma territorial qui peuvent être vous
avez dit on a envie d'entendre qu'ils
seront mobilisés oui mais quand je dis
que c'est à dire c'est pour dire qu'une
certaine possibilité puisque ils sont là
maintenant pour les utiliser il faut
aller sous des appels à projets ce sont
des des fonds des fonds feder parce que
qui fait après qui fait les actions ce
sont eux qui mènent des actions ce sont
les entreprises qui mènent des actions
il faut que dans l'eau dans le rôle dans
leurs activités qu'elles puissent dans
leurs projets mobiliser ces fonds qui
sont sur le territoire alors le principe
de ce schéma territorial été votée en
mai 2010 est son plan d'action une ans
plus tard en février 2018 les actions
concrètes sur le terrain visible
mesurables et quantifiables à partir de
quand
ben déjà et c'est pour ça que nous
étions à madiana c'était pour montrer
que nous avons nous avons commencé déjà
bien bien longtemps
je donne un exemple sur la compétitivité
des entreprises nous voulons aller sur
deux là nous voulons inciter des
entreprises à faire leur transformation
numérique
il ya eu le salon aux où c'était le
thème principal il y à des dispositifs
aujourd'hui qui sont mis en place par la
ctm par la chambre de commerce
par espace sud donc on est tous derrière
la transformation numérique est pour
vous dire comment il ya de la cohérence
sur le terrain il faut que le si nous
faisons de la transformation numérique
il faut que le terrain notre notre
territoire soit équipé aujourd'hui le
maillage de la fibre optique que nous
avons c'est un programme de plus de 108
millions d'euros qui aujourd'hui est
accompagné par l'état à plus de 50
millions d'euros
et c'est là que nous voyons comment
l'état s'implique à nos côtés parce que
c'est fait comment sur le terrain les
allées les acteurs de l'économie ne le
ressentent non c'est bon il ya si
longtemps que cela nous avons reçu par
exemple le président de l'association
martinique tech c'est quand même une
centaine d'entre cinquantaine
d'entreprises tournées vers le numérique
qui se disent les politiques ne nous
suivent pas
non non au financement ailleurs et puis
si un jour ils veulent comprendre le
comprendre non parce qu'il ya des appels
à projets répondent à des appels à
projets non non je pense que et en plus
nous avons des dispositifs où nous
accompagnons cette transformation
numérique donc et si les eaux et si les
entreprises se transforme au niveau 2 de
l'outil numérique
les entreprises qui sont dans le
numérique auront des marchés donc c'est
vraiment n'ont su ce que je voulais dire
sous ses 108 millions d'euros 50
millions d'euros apportés par l'état
ce sera votée dans le ce se sera plus le
feder nous apporte 34 millions ce sera
votée à la prochaine plénière et c'est
un effort sans précédent ça faisait
longtemps que l'état ne venait pas comme
financeur principal sur une opération
manette hors pays les schémas
économiques à chaque mandature on
avec quelques nuances parfois politiques
parfois idéologique mais qui reprennent
chaque fois quand même les mêmes grands
principes on est quand même habitué à ne
pas être si emballé que cela à être
habitués qui à chaque changement de
gouvernance eh bien on refait d'être un
dieu
non non pas du tout alors c'est vrai
qu'on peut dire un schéma de plus mais
ça ce n'est pas un schéma de plus parce
que d'abord vous avez ce plan d'action
d'abord la démarche est aujourd'hui ce
qui traîne on n'y avait pas de plan
d'action des halles jan talich veux
d'abord vous avez une démarche
partenariale on est pas on n'a pas la
science infuse à la 7è on l'a vraiment
fait avec nos partenaires et en plus de
ça la structuration connaître dieu non
la la la la structuration est simple et
efficace
elle est différente de ces schémas qui
sont alambiqués non là elle est simple
nous avons fait un diagnostic les
mesures transversales qui sont prises
pour tous les secteurs d'activité sont
clairement définis et en plus après nous
avons choisi nos trois filières
prioritaires porteuse pour nous de
d'emplois et d'activités tout ce nouveau
développement économique se dit ce matin
en écoutant alléluia mène mais non mais
non mais non envie de moi cela que vous
avez présenté largement la semaine
dernière en sachant qu'il ne reste plus
que deux ans avant le réveil de la
gouvernance au sein de la cei à un
moment on freine des deux pieds sur les
questions des finances non non c'est
parce que j'étais nous du rêve mais ce
que je voudrais mais c'est ce que je
suis ce que je suis en train de faire
regardez sur regardez par exemple notre
exemple d'une entreprise parce que d'une
entreprise qui skie qui s'est présentée
à madiana
cette entreprise elle elle travaille sur
comment d'aidé d'éclat au décor et
desclaux déconner les la terre les sols
de la martinique donc avec du charbon
actif que l'on va récupérer dans les
boues d'assainissement il ya tout
principe qu'ils sont en train de mettre
en place
là c'est nous et nous allons soutenir
cette initiative
cette action qui est fortement pour nous
donne économique et oculaires qui est en
plus de l'innovation et glee ya d'autres
exemples comme ça sur sur l'énergie et
l'énergie la transition énergétique
là aussi nous devons être nous devons
être productif et nous
vont être imaginatif créatif surtout
cesser ce jeudi reste ces actions qui
sont créatives qui sont innovantes
nous sommes là avec le plan de
convergence qui devient maintenant le
plan de convergence que nous avons nous
avons les fonds européens nous avons les
fonds ctm tous les dispositifs sont là
et les entreprises qui lorsqu'on est en
réunion plénière qu'on dise il commettra
trop d'argent non sur tel projet car je
suis les noms des dix sept et dix ans la
chef d'entreprise on a bien l'élu de moi
je suis découragée qui ne pas voir le
projet aboutir parce que mais l'agent
cats à des privés oui non et il y as
après il ya un temps administratif qui
est de plus en plus logique qui n'est
pas là c'est le tonneau mais il me l'a
dit leur confiance des os dédié qui
aujourd'hui de plus en plus réduit donc
bon ce que ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse c'est que c'est vraiment
faire savoir tout ce que nous avons fait
pour ceux comme cool alors tout ce que
nous avons fait aujourd'hui pour que
nous ayons un développement sur la
médication productif
oui non mais vous vous vous dites vous
dit ça mais regardez les perspectives on
à la production du lait voir la
production cac café cacao
ces deux productions aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont qui ont trouvé leur excellence
parce qu'elles sont du terroir
martiniquais donc ses productions nous
allons effectivement aussi bas avec des
dispositifs les soutenir et une dernière
production parce qu'une dernière action
on à papa et de l'employabilité au genre
y arriver aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de préparer un dispositif qui
s'appelle crystal reed dans ce
dispositif que nous travaillons avec
donc c'est la ctm pôle emploi la cdc et
des banques privées pour mettre en place
un dispositif pour emmener les
demandeurs d'emploi à créer leur
activité dans de bonnes conditions et
avec un modèle économique et syrie
si tu as entendu mon très longs soupirs
lorsque vous avez des banques privées de
soutien financier à ces jeunes
entrepreneurs qui veulent seulement
c'est la question du financement est
toujours mes dédicaces des modèles
économiques équilibrées l'accompagnement
est primordial c'est quoi un modèle
économique équilibré ce que vous faites
une action il faut que vous recettes au
moins soit puisse couvrir vos chances si
ces déséquilibres et vous aurez des
problèmes
cc en moins 600 +1 basse énergie
nous avons une égérie très forte en
martinique le problème c'est que toutes
ces bonnes idées ne sont pas forcément
aidé parce qu'ils manquent peut-être les
coachs du côté des finances de lait
coûte peut-être des politiques
au jour d'aujourd'hui pourquoi vous ne
pensez pas monsieur viol ton
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes partis sur
une nouvelle dynamique
nous avons regardé déjà comme la scène
non pas du tout cette chanson
non pas du tout cette stratégie cette
stratégie est effectivement aujourd'hui
très clair les orientations sont donnés
le tourisme par contre quel l'une des
filières que nous avons fléché le
tourisme et la filière qui qui impacte
le plus l'activité
quand on regarde sur le tour isa par les
hôtels puisque nous voulons faire du
tourisme durable et patrimonial à part
les hôtels restaurants la culture peut
être impacté avec des circuits des
circuits a fait elle décide à faire à
visiter nous avons des deux gîtes peau
chez l'habitant
donc le touriste est pour nous la
filière porteuse qui va nous apporter
beaucoup d'activité d'emploi il y aura
beaucoup de choses encore à dire à ce
pour quoi pour vous de ce schéma
territorial malheureusement sont pris
par le temps merci d'avoir été ce matin
avec nous mardi si le chien conseillère
exécutive en charge du développement
économique à propos de hull de ce st
de26